tâm của tế với hợp tác lên sân cùng hã sữa ốc hơn 18.9.
Bối tình qua nhiều cơ quan bảo chì ư tiến tại ốc đã đồng loạt đưa tiến về sự kiện hợp tác
xin lực sữa ư tế ốc. Sân nghiệp sữa Việt Nam và Vy Plus Derry, tâm hiệu có bệ giải lực sữa hơn 18.9.
Theo đó, hai bên chính thức công bộ thình lập tâm yệu sữa ốc tế mang tên Gibbs đầy chờ với sang một sân phẩm đà giạ.
Từ sữa công thức cho chẻ em, người chừng thành người lớn tùy. Đây không chỉ là một mốc đánh sấu bức đi
tần cầu hoa só nét của nụ tí phút. Mà con khẳng định vị thế Quốc tế của tương nghiệp việt khi đồng sáng lập một tương nghiệp
sữa với một nhà sản xuất tử ốc. Bối lấy khi kết sĩnh ra chăng trong với sự hiện dịnh của nhiều lãnh đạo cấp cao và đại dịnh chính phủ hai nước.
Fio có ông KVNN Mình, khoảng lý cấp cao phủ chắc kinh nối tần cầu. Vy ban thương mại và đầu tư ốc chơi liá ông
vô đà ăn bà nạ, cuối vân chính lực ban phòng thương mại và đầu tư chính quyền băng Victoria tại đông nằm á.
Bà anh đi giang, giám đốc đầu tư quốc tế hút vực châu Á và Trung Đông bóc vì cuộc cơ quan đầu tư Vyctoria,
phía Việt Nam có ông Kim Sơn Hoa, tham tán công sử, phó đại sự quan Việt Nam tại uc,
sự kiện còn tư hút sự chú ý đặc biệt từ cộng Đông Xanh Ninh. Vy cí và KVO Lội bật như Xanh Ninh Hân Nà,
O Lala, Xanh Pênh Dinh Gọc Zip, Đạo Zinh Vyctor vũ, Xanh Ninh Lâm Thánh Kinh, ông trên bảo miên,
phó chú tịch hội đồng quan chỉ lúc tí phó cùng CEO của Vyctoria Derry đã khẳng định mục tiêu chung cuộc cả hợp tác,
chúng tôi không chỉ sản xuất sữa, chúng tôi sẵn tạo ra dài pháp dính giữ trước lực cao.
Vyctoria của quán chuyển thông quốc tế lớn cùng đưa tin đã có phần khẳng định tâm bóc,
sự ki vọng của giới đầu tư và người thư dùng dành cho thương giữ Gibbs Nature.
Dự kiến sẽ giám mắt tại Việt Nam vào cuối bán năm 2018.